homeowners in oregon evacuation zones
are now worried about their belongings
being stolen while they're not home
our reporter kate houston is live
tonight outside the clackamas county
sheriff's office
which is about 11 miles southeast of
portland so
deputies have received many calls over
the past week
yeah that's right sasha the sheriff's
department says calls for service have
exploded in level two and level three
evacuation zones
many of these are reports for suspicious
people cars and
concerns about burglaries i spoke to a
family who says
that their home was looted after they
had to evacuate from estacada
this week the patterson family left
their home on tuesday
as evacuation levels were increasing on
friday morning they got a notification
from their alarm system
saying someone went inside their home
video of the aftermath shows
red bull cans thrown around the kitchen
dog food
everywhere and many items stolen chuck
patterson tells me over 60 necklaces
and 100 pairs of his wife's earrings are
missing
much of it was passed down by family
members some were from patterson himself
as they were dating in high school
he tells me his wife is devastated and
he's furious
we just want to get back to our home but
with the smoke there we can't get back
my son is actually at the house down
he's you know it's a level three
evacuation
and my son is risking his life to stay
in our house
to make it so idiots don't do this
patterson shared these videos and photos
taken from his doorbell camera
the family says they found knives around
the house and a bb gun sitting outside
as well
they're asking anyone with information
to contact the police
now the clackamas county sheriff's
office will be increasing patrols
in level two and level three evacuation
zones and this is to protect homes
and businesses reporting live from
clackamas oregon tonight kate houston 8
news now
so kate is the sheriff's office
receiving any help with the amount of
calls they're getting and of course the
magnitude of these evacuations
yes they are sasha the multnomah county
sheriff's office and
oregon state police are here to assist
them and they say
that from tuesday to thursday this week
they had 330 calls
for suspicious activity and that's more
than a 400 percent increase from the
days before
thank you so much and stay safe out
there sally